let's stay with the phones who else do
we have here a lot of people want to get
in here how about two oh one caller from
201 if you can hear me tell me who this
is and what's on your mind today
hey Dave this is Dan big fan TV show so
it's a quick question so it seems the
power of aluminum ports is coming
especially with Gary Cohn leaving and
then kind of some of the tweets that
president Trump's been tweeting out yeah
so my question is has there been any
historical examples of some sort of
super PAC coming together across
industry because I feel like this would
have some sort of a big backlash you
know across party aisles especially
coming into the mid term and then to
know 2020 to do what though you're
saying because of the steel tariffs yet
the challenge the I guess you know Trump
and their economic agenda yeah I'm just
not sure that that's gonna I mean listen
I don't think a super PAC is the way to
do it I think super PACs are part of the
problem not the solution I think
basically it's a matter of just people
people need to get out and vote voter
turnout is pathetically low I'm not
really looking to the idea of a super
PAC to deal with the steel tariffs thing
I mean it you're you're not gonna win a
trade war it's more who's gonna lose
less and I think it's disastrous
economic but I wouldn't go to a super
PAC to try to fix that well I mean I
understand that but do you think that
would be the response from industry no I
don't I think that industry will just
donate to either existing super PACs or
candidates that they think would be
friendly to them but I don't I don't
know that I mean listen there's a
million super PACs already there's
probably already one that is working
specifically with companies from the
manufacturing industry so I don't think
we need to go to a new we've got plenty
of super PACs let's put it that way
there the call very much appreciate it
good to be thinking about ways to deal
with with the tariff issue no no doubt
about it